in this video I want to discuss what
they don't tell you when they remove
your gallbladder okay when they remove
the gallbladder you will eventually have
what's called a bile deficiency okay now
bile is like detergent for grease or fat
so if you could imagine having greasy
hands and washing your hands without any
detergent that wouldn't work right so
trying to eat food without something to
break the food down especially the fats
it's not going to break down fully so
we're gonna have an incomplete digestion
of fat and essential fatty acids like
omega-3 fatty acids which are very
important for nerve brain eyes heart and
fat soluble vitamins vitamin A D E in k
so eventually you could become deficient
in those because you don't have a
gallbladder and so you're not going to
have the concentrated bile in there
anymore it's just going to trickle down
from the liver so the constant drip and
that can affect you in very many ways
like increased risk for a fatty liver
because bile is necessary to break down
cholesterol okay and fats so your risk
goes up with the fatty liver unless you
change your diet you can have diarrhea
or constipation depending on how much
bile is coming out if too much is coming
out you're gonna have diarrhea or anal
leakage okay if not enough is trickling
out you can have constipation because
bile really interacts with the microbes
it also acts to lubricate the colon bile
is also necessary to help prevent
bloating so you might have more bloating
indigestion incomplete digestion in
general okay so we already talked about
not being able to fully break down your
fats the stool might float that means
you're not breaking down those fats but
the liver normally makes 350 milligrams
of bile every single day but the problem
is you don't have a little sec to
concentrate that
because anytime you eat you're supposed
to squeeze out this concentrated bile to
do its job we have a diluted form of
bile which is a lot different now the
other thing that you get to realize is
that certain fats require bile and some
fats do not require a file and that's
what you need to know about as well MCT
oil okay in a certain portion of butter
palm oil bypasses the gall bladder and
it goes right into the intestines so
those oils are much easier to digest
avocado oil olive oil nuts nut oils
saturated fats are they need bile to
break it down so just realize that if
you consume these fats only and none of
these fats you might find a lot of
problems with digestion so you might
want to shift some of the fats that
you're consuming but you also need to
consume omega-3 fatty acids that's
really really important that has
something called DHA and EPA cod liver
oil gives you a good amount so that's a
really important thing I would also
recommend watching my video I put a link
down below of all the things that will
help output bile from your liver okay
and you probably even want to get a bile
salt supplement to help you alright
thanks for watching so I want to know
about what you think about this video so
please comment below and tell me what
you think